this is a millionaire theme our one of
your favorite hours that I do on this
show and one of mine as well
what's a millionaire themed hour well I
guess about two years ago we decided to
occasionally take an hour and take calls
only from millionaires and ask them how
they did it because if you want to be
skinny you know what you do you ask
skinny people if you want to be
successful in business you know what you
do you ask people that are successful in
business if you want to grow hair
you don't ask me I don't have any if you
want to be married for many years you
don't ask somebody has been married 14
times with an opinion you ask somebody's
been married 67 years how'd you do that
it's called best practices you emulate
people that are successful you learn
from people that are really successful
and one of the things you have to do in
the process is you have to stop
believing mythology about the area you
have to stop believing the lies about
the area of your life you want to get
better at and there are lies about
millionaires there are lies about the
wealthy that are out there and they're
particularly loud in the middle of this
ridiculous political season all the
wealthy inherited their money we need to
do wealth redistribution because it gets
stuck with the wealthy families lie only
way to get rich is to be crooked and
steal from people all those rich people
are crooks lie those rich people are
really they're all rockstars and
professional athletes and actors lie
rich people are all brilliant I'm not
that smart why see very few have a 4.0
less than 1% of America's millionaires
are entertainers athletes very very
fewer crooks because people don't do
business with crooks they fire them
and they make the news but they really
it is Anna proven method of building
wealth and nine out of ten eighty eight
percent of America's millionaires are
first-generation rich they did not
inherit it so I'm going to prove it to
you I'm going to take calls this hour
from millionaires real millionaires a
million dollar net worth is it means
that what you own minus what you owe is
more than a million dollars your net
assets minus your net liabilities equals
1 million dollars it has nothing to do
your income you can have a high income
or low income million dollar a year
income is not does not make you a
millionaire it's not what a millionaire
is now they're stupid politicians on the
national scene that don't even know the
definition of this but that is the
technical definition of a millionaire
and the actual only real definition of a
millionaire so we're going to talk to
real millionaires and find out about
them so you can find out how to really
do this Karen is going to start us off
she's in Madison Wisconsin hi Karen how
are you I'm good how are you Dave
better than I deserve what's your net
worth ma'am about 2 5 2 to 7 somewhere
in there okay cool and what's it
invested in about 70% is in our retire
IRAs about 20% or and other investments
mutual fund savings emergency funds that
kind of thing about 10% in our house
okay so you got about a $300,000 house
okay and the rest is basically in mutual
funds of some kind whether it's 401ks or
IRAs or or otherwise right right very
good and so uh how old are you uh 69
okay cool
how much of this did you inherit um none
of this no car did we inherit although
my parents do have a trust set up that
after their death but that's not
included in this at all this is what we
did on our own yeah and you haven't got
any of this money because of that trust
is what you're saying correct okay cool
and through your working lifetime what's
been your range of income your household
income oh well my husband and I are were
teachers are both retired teachers and
so we started teaching about 46 years
ago started out at about combined
$14,000 a year when we started when we
retired we were earning combined about a
hundred and twenty-five thousand so you
did all of this on that Wow
yes okay so your degrees are in
education correct okay and what were
your GPAs mine was about a three five my
husband was a little less than that all
right so you're smart but you didn't
make all this money because you're a
genius
no okay how much money did you how much
of this money of your wealth is there
because you borrowed money to create
wealth
oh absolutely none of it okay and what
what part has giving played in your
financial plan well we've been and are
currently helping family and they're
very happy to do that and we hope to do
more and once we kind of have that
pretty well taken care of we have plans
what we'd like to do is do some giving
aspect like to education scholarships
funds and since we are teachers yeah I
would make sense right yeah what's the
most expensive pair blue jeans your
robot twenty-five dollars not at okay
and how many brand-new cars did you buy
before you had 2.6 million dollars
oh we did have a few but it's been a
combination of new and used cars and
we've always kept them around ten years
or so and we know we don't buy them very
often we always pay cash for them okay
all right very cool okay so if you're do
you think that this can still be done I
mean you're worth almost three million
dollars and you were two teachers and
you did it through your working lifetime
I'm guessing you just did it with steady
saving and investing right that's
absolutely what it was yes yeah and like
my parents were good role models that
way because with what my parents said
they didn't
and I might add with a federal employee
he didn't oh I forgot to ask you how
much of this money did you steal we
didn't steal any well you always hear
millionaires or crooks oh I just want to
check role models for us taught us you
know so we kind of followed their fear
of what they taught us over the years so
what would your a teacher what would
your advice be to the 25 year old
version of you that's listening to this
well a lot of what my own parents taught
me they said you know start saving early
pay yourself first take advantage of all
the opportunities that your job offers
you don't pay by something less you can
pay cash for it education is important
but I'd also say that college isn't for
everyone but regardless anybody is when
you graduate from high school you still
need some kind of training beyond high
school in order to get some kind of a
decent paying job and you know just set
goals you know for yourself prioritize
them and it's just small steps along the
way there you go that's how you do it
right there Karen just told you she's
worth 2.6 million carrying your great
American Hero
you did it you're a millionaire times
three this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you can do this you know that really is
a message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or 27 thousand well you've got a
fifty thousand dollar income or five
hundred thousand dollar income
you